[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 j'espère que le week-end a été bon on
démarre la soirée ensemble avec de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici le programme de ce
mardi 11 avril
l'hommage de l'académie de Versailles à
Ginette kolinca ce matin le rectorat
inauguré dans ses locaux une salle
portant le nom de la survivante du camp
de concentration et d'extermination
d'Auschwitz la passeuse de mémoire âgée
de 98 ans était présente pour l'occasion
son témoignage dans cette édition un
retour après 9 ans d'absence pour la
première fois depuis 2014 Magnanville
accueillait le départ de la mythique
Paris camembert la 84e édition de la
course cycliste s'était lancé ce matin
des Yvelines direction et livaro pays
d'Oh après 200 km de parcours et des
centaines de personnes sont venues
assister au départ un village
d'animation était également installé à
Magnanville nous étions sur place
et puis il fait partie des plats
préférés des français le burger à sa
coupe de France la 8e édition de cet
événement original se tient demain au
salon sandwich and Snack Show à Paris
parmi les finalistes de l'équipe
Île-de-France un yvelinois Anthony potra
qui présentera de who sa création il est
chef de cuisine à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et nous l'avons suivi dans sa
préparation
et d'habitude il vient le lundi en
plateau là c'est mardi puisqu'il y a eu
un lundi férié cette semaine c'est
Michael et le midoro bonsoir bonsoir je
suis toujours là
journaliste en charge des sports aussi
un sur TV 78 avec vous on va voir ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité
sportive du week-end puisque même si il
y a eu un week-end prolongé il y a que
quand même des équipes qui sont allées
sur les terrains ce week-end oui
quelques équipes tous les matchs
n'étaient pas programmés ce week-end un
week-end de Pâques oblige mais il y a eu
quand même quelques matchs Versailles a
fait match nul on reviendra sur ce match
de national dans quelques instants il y
avait également les demi-finales de la
Coupe des Yvelines et nous parlerons
également handball avec la Nationale 3
masculine dans la partie sport on aura
également un invité tout à l'heure un
invité qui est juste en face de nous
paul-hermitage ancien directeur du Golf
National de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui a œuvré pour cette Ryder Cup 2018
sur ce golf national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et vous allez
travailler sur les Jeux olympiques de
bonsoir merci bonsoir alors pourquoi
pourquoi avoir pris le poste alors
est-ce que déjà d'avoir cette chance de
faire les deux plus gros événements
golfique qui existent sur terre est-ce
que ça se refuse déjà c'est un coup de
fil qui est venu comme ça elle était
dernier et dans un premier temps j'ai
dit non j'étais en train de m'installer
confortablement dans une dans une chaise
dans un autre poste
après deux ans et demi après avoir
quitté le Golf National et puis ça m'a
fait tourner la tête et je te trois
jours plus tard il y a après avoir parlé
avec la famille faire les plus les moins
non ça se refuse pas ça se refuse pas de
de venir travailler sur des événements
sur un événement olympique qui arrive
maintenant moins de 480 jours très
exactement j'ai pu le chiffre en tête on
va le regarder au cours de cette
émission on aura l'occasion de parler de
vos missions et de votre prise de poste
pour CGO de Paris 2024 en Céline Charles
de la rédaction tv78 bonsoir avec vous
on va voir ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité de ce mardi 11 avril les
actualités culturelles également au menu
du 7 8 le mentaliste magicien et
comédien Mathieu villatel sur avec nous
tout à l'heure il nous parlera du
spectacle Cérébro qui est au programme
ce samedi au scarabée à la verrière et
puis comme chaque mardi les insolites de
Véronique pour peut-être voir les
informations qui vous ont échappé dans
les Yvelines tout cela bien sûr ce sera
après les prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
il va falloir patienter encore un peu
avant de retrouver des conditions météo
idéales et conditions météo similaires
du week-end pascal avec des nuages qui
sont au menu de votre matinée de
mercredi dans le département côté
température comptait 9 degrés sur les
secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans les
Versailles 8 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi attention le temps sera
rageux et les Yvelines seront en
vigilance jaune au vent prévoyez 11
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Rambouillet 12 degrés à Houdan et demain
c'est la saint Jules le point à présent
sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines
et on commence ces lignes avec cette
information le lancement du satellite
inspire 7 seven de l'Université de
Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines encore
reporté oui le Nano satellite devait
être mise en orbite ce matin depuis la
Californie mais son lancement est
reporté à demain écoutez
qui sont qui sont liés à spécix ça ça
arrive régulièrement donc ça nous
surprend pas le lancement à chaque fois
faut qu'il de succès donc on ne lance
pas une fusée si on est pas certain que
que tout est tout est vert donc là ça
n'a rien à voir avec nos projets c'est
vraiment le décalage mais on a déjà
connu ça avec U vsqad donc on est on est
habitué à ces décalages et on le
rappelle un spider 7 7 c'est le deuxième
nano satellite conçu par le l'Atmos
laboratoire atmosphère milieu
observation spatiale de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines il
va rejoindre UVs cusate lancée en 2021
dans l'espace à 550 km d'altitude pour
former une constellation un spyer 7 7
sera dédié à l'observation de la Terre
et du soleil le lancement est donc prévu
demain mercredi 12 avril aux alentours
de 8h30 depuis la base américaine de Van
derbirg en Californie une vidéo à
présent qui a fait le tour de la toile
et qui fait polémique celle de
l'interpellation musclée d'un jeune
lycéen et c'est devant le lycée Jules
Ferry à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine tout à
fait Grégory les faits se sont déroulés
le jeudi 6 avril dernier ou une centaine
d'élèves du lycée Jules Ferry ont bloqué
l'entrée de l'établissement à l'occasion
de la journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites plusieurs vidéos
qui ont fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
montre l'arrestation d'un adolescent
devant le lycée le jeune est plaqué au
sol par plusieurs policiers pendant
plusieurs secondes des images qui ont
suscité une vie réaction notamment du
côté de plusieurs responsables
politiques comme par exemple Nadia et
député renaissance des Yvelines qui
précise sur Twitter avoir je cite saisis
le préfet pour avoir des explications
sur ces images très troublantes la
préfecture des Yvelines a également
réagi en indiquant que la personne
interpellée était un individu masqué
ayant tenté de se soustraire au contrôle
il a été libéré et remis à ses parents
sans faire l'objet de poursuites qui
font fausses en ce moment à une
situation exceptionnelle en termes de
sécheresse oui c'est une situation comme
vous l'avez dit exceptionnelle et
préoccupante en raison de la période de
sécheresse hivernale et ce malgré le
retour des pluies au mois de mars l'état
de sécheresse et la dégradation des
nappes phréatiques à mener le préfet des
Yvelines a renforcé les mesures de
limitation des usages de l'eau dans la
zone centrale du département qui passe
en situation de vigilance parmi les
villes concernées plaisir Villepreux
Élancourt ou encore Versailles vous
pouvez trouver la liste complète sur le
site de la préfecture concernant le
reste du département le préfet appelle à
l'économie dans l'usage de l'eau qu'il
qualifie de l'affaire de tous et pour
terminer on sort d'un weekend de Pascal
forcément plusieurs événements dans les
Yvelines pour aller chercher son
chocolat exactement où il est clashs
sont passés ce weekend et les amoureux
de
Showa quelques photos prises à
différents endroits du département au
château de Breteuil à Choisel par
exemple 14000 œufs étaient à retrouver
sur près de deux hectares le Domaine de
Dampierre-en-Yvelines a également été
généreux sur les surprises chocolatées à
condition de répondre à plusieurs
énigmes enfin aux fermes de Gally de
Saint-Cyr-l'École les petits aventuriers
ont pu chercher des œufs aux quatre
coins de la ferme la chaussée était
bonne nickel ce weekend c'était très
bonne ce week-end effectivement alors
vous avez vu la dernière photo c'était
la mienne parce que je suis allé au
ferme de Gally ce week-end et c'était
très sympa j'ai beaucoup de chocolat
beaucoup de chocolat oui oui je bon avec
modération toujours évidemment merci en
tout cas c'est une pour ces informations
et si vous aussi près de chez vous voyez
une information une actualité qui vous
fait réagir n'hésitez pas à la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
je vous en parlais dans les titres
l'académie de Versailles a rendu hommage
à Ginette colinka ce matin le rectorat
inauguré dans ses locaux une salle
portant le nom de la à survivant du camp
d'ex destination et de concentration
d'Auschwitz elle a passeuse de mémoire
âgée de 98 ans était présente pour
l'occasion au régime ralech et vous
aussi Céline Charles ont recueilli son
témoignage aujourd'hui au rectorat de
l'académie de Versailles à mes côtés
Ginette kolinca bonjour
alors vous êtes survivants des camps de
concentration et d'extermination
daousbeech Birkenau aujourd'hui c'est
salle vient d'être inaugurée à votre nom
on en parlera dans quelques instants
juste avant je vous propose d'écouter
l'interview express de la reprise
académie de Versailles Charline Avenel
[Musique]
le 8 mars dernier nous avons fait voter
les personnels du rectorat sur plusieurs
noms pour donner à cette salle qui est
la salle majeure de du rectorat de
Versailles celle où nous faisons toutes
les réunions pour pouvoir lui donner le
nom d'une femme et moi je souhaitais que
ce soit une femme et une femme qui a un
lien avec la transmission et donc j'ai
proposé parmi les longs les noms
sur lesquels faire voter le nom de
Ginette kolinca
[Musique]
elle nous raconte à la fois l'horreur et
puis ce qu'elle nous raconte aussi c'est
son puissant désir de vivre d'être
heureuse depuis que qu'elle est sortie
des camps et elle nous donne aussi le
son évidemment c'est là tout son propos
avec les jeunes à propos qui vise à
lutter contre la haine contre le racisme
contre l'antisémitisme et qui apprend
beaucoup pour vivre en somme
[Musique]
c'est difficile aujourd'hui dans les
écoles de France de parler de ce moment
de la Shoah c'est difficile parce que
les élèves sont sensibles on perd
progressivement la mémoire et donc plus
que jamais c'est nécessaire et il faut
s'appeler à cette tâche de transmission
de mémoire il faut s'y atteler pour ne
pas oublier le passé parce que le passé
est clair sur le présent et sur l'avenir
[Musique]
nous sommes actuellement dans cette
salle qui porte votre nom qu'est-ce que
ça fait d'avoir une salle justement qui
porte votre nom ça me semble tellement
grand que j'y crois pas ça me semble
trop grand trop important pourquoi moi
mais pourquoi pas les autres elles
auront fait elles ont souffert comme moi
et il y en a aussi qui parle comme moi
alors j'avoue franchement que tous ces
honneurs c'est agréable mais d'un autre
côté c'est excessif et ça me gêne et
vous aviez dit tout à l'heure que
parfois vous vous rendiez en classe et
vous demandez au plus jeune de moins de
15 ans de se lever quand j'ai demandé
aux jeunes de se lever c'est parce que
pour leur prouver que les paroles
lecture
on écoute on lit mais on sera pas compte
mais quand vous avez une classe de
troisième où vous dites aux élèves ceux
qui ont moins de 15 ans levez-vous et
que vous voyez toute la classe qui se
lève et je leur dis
on vous aurait tué alors là oui il se
rendent compte vous aviez également
mentionné tout à l'heure que pendant
près de 40 ans vous n'aviez pas parlé de
ce passé exact 40 ans un peu plus ça
peut moi ça je sais pas non non mais moi
je voulais pas en parler quand j'ai
appris que la guerre était finie
la première première chose que j'ai
pensé
Ginette tu raconteras pas ton histoire
t'embêtera pas les gens à raconter ce
que tu as vécu pas parce que je voulais
pas dire que j'avais t'aider parce que
je ne voulais pas embêter les gens à
entendre toujours la même histoire pour
ne plus que ça se reproduise quel
message aujourd'hui vous souhaitez faire
passer
accepter l'autre comme il est avec ses
qualités avec ses défauts avec sa
couleur de peau avec sa religion
pourquoi que je vous empêcherai de vivre
vous n'êtes pas juif vous noir alors
vous êtes bon à rien pas juive et noir
ben non vous êtes un être humain bien
merci Madame colinka c'est très gentil
de m'avoir accordé cette interview il y
a pas de quoi
il y a quelques jours l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
organisée une conférence et projection
autour des droits des femmes d'hier à
aujourd'hui trois femmes venu d'horizon
divers ont pu témoigner devant les
étudiants toute cette semaine nous
proposons leur interview premier numéro
ce soir avec Catherine schlemer qui est
directrice des relations publiques au
Théâtre de Poche Montparnasse
s'interrogeait par Céline Charles
[Musique]
je m'occupe des relations je me dirige
la relation publique du Théâtre de Poche
Montparnasse
j'ai eu de en gros trois vies
professionnelles puisque j'ai été
infirmière en réanimation pendant une
dizaine d'années tout en faisant un
diplôme de psychopathe psychanalyse un
boss et puis ensuite j'ai été mère au
foyer 17 ans et ensuite je suis rentré
dans le monde du spectacle vivant
faisant de la production de la diffusion
parler du fait qu'on peut changer de vie
professionnelle et par rapport à la
condition des femmes autrefois où ont
finalement soit on travaillait pas soit
on travaillait parce qu'on était obligé
quand moi j'étais jeune
on faisait un métier et à la limite
entre guillemets on pensait que c'était
pour la vie et finalement de mon âge
j'ai 60 je vais avoir 67 ans il y a peu
de il y a peu de
personnes qui ont eu plusieurs métiers
c'était impensable le but c'était
d'avoir un seul métier de voilà et
moi-même je n'y pensais même pas quand
j'ai commencé
[Musique]
qui vont être amenés forcément avoir
plusieurs métiers dans la vie mais de
voir que c'est tout à fait possible et
que si on suit un peu ces passions mais
il faut quand même avoir une assise
financière derrière avoir une
possibilité de trouver du travail
puisque il faut vivre mais après on peut
justement faire fructifier ses passions
et l'important c'est dans l'avoir
surtout
[Rires]
[Musique]
la suite demain et jeudi sur TV 78 allez
on ouvre une page de sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
toujours avec Michael elmidoro et Paul
ermitage du Golf National de 50 ans en
Yvelines on disait qu'il vient d'être
nommé au sport manager sport très
précisément sport manager même au golf
du Golfe au comité d'organisation des
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 voilà j'ai
remis tout toutes les données dans le
bon sens des épreuves bien sûr de golf
vont se dérouler sur le territoire des
Yvelines au Golf National de 50 ans en
Yvelines où nous disiez tout à l'heure
pour les remitage que vous n'avez pas
hésité très longtemps avant de donner
votre aval votre accord pour pour cette
mission comment ça s'est fait justement
vous avez commencé à le dire comment
c'est fait cette nomination et comment
la prise de contact s'est-elle faite la
prise de contact est venue de part
européen tour quand on est bien parce
qu'ils ont organisent l'Open de France
et puis et puis la Ryder Cup qui
détenteur de droits de riders Cup parce
qu'ils font partie eux d'un consortium
qui a été créé pour les jeux qui est
dirigé par le international de la
Fédération internationale de golf comme
les fédérations fonctionne tous les
sports de des JO et qui a réuni tous les
experts du golf vendu donc le DP World
Tour européen tour la péja tour qui est
américain Ladies Tour européen et
américain et la Fédération Française de
Golf donc sans font partie d'un
consommateur qui vont livrer le côté
sportif
du Golfe et il cherchait effectivement
quelqu'un
maintenant a été je pense tiré au sort
non je pense est sorti de du chapeau et
voilà comment est venu le contact de par
2018 il y a une expérience à la tête du
Golf National mais surtout à la tête du
Golf National pendant un événement
majeur comme la Ryder Cup en 2018 je
pense que ça a pesé dans la balance oui
je pense qu'il est 7 6 7 années au golf
national sont effectivement
la raison pour laquelle j'étais choisi
il y avait pas vraiment l'avènement
parce que la Ryder Cup était organisé
par une organisation internationale mais
mais déjà de préparer le golf non là une
telle épreuve pour accueillir le monde
entier à ce niveau là bon c'est c'est
clair que ça c'est ça c'est plutôt bien
passé et de mettre en place les équipes
et puis l'expérience golfeur etc tout ce
que vous connaissez déjà là-bas alors
porte Manager au sein du comité
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en charge du Golfe
concrètement c'est quoi ça va être quoi
votre mission alors en fait il y a ce
qu'on appelle aussi je vais parler
beaucoup anglais mais il y a un CDE
qui livre le sport qui est externalisé à
Paris 2024 c'est uniquement c'est
seulement dans le golf qu'on voit ça
tous les autres CDE sont internalisés à
parler des mécanes donc en fait moi je
suis salarié d'une fédération
internationale et qui a été missionné
par Eden 204 pour le golf dans mon rôle
consiste à créer l'équipe de ce CDE
une équipe de professionnels pour
pouvoir
livrer tout ce que a besoin les athlètes
pour aller vers la livraison des
médailles on va dire en passant par une
partie de la préparation du parcours
avec les agronomistes et puis Lucas
pierre et que qui est le l'intendant au
golf national en passant par le la
préparation du site pour
les athlètes au niveau de de du jeu
voilà donc toute la partie sportive tout
ce que ça peut comprendre sachant que il
y a la partie événementielle donc tout
ce qui est hospitalité tente transport
par les les services de Paris 4 et on
est obligé de travailler ensemble pour
le transport des athlètes pour le
médical pour le dopping pour etc etc etc
donc il y a énormément de différentes
domaines à penser et c'est une
organisation qui est complètement
différente de la Ryder comme donc
j'apprends aussi tous les jours et c'est
ça qui m'a aussi fait venir dans ce rôle
c'est d'apprendre également
et comment ça va se dérouler avec
Philippe pilateau qui l'actuel directeur
du Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines très bien très
bien parce que on est je dirais pas je
dirais pas jusqu'à dire frère mais mais
presque
Philips et c'est quelqu'un qui je
retrouve au golf en 2013 quand je suis
arrivé qui avait une toute autre mission
il a une telle empathie telle sympathie
c'est quelqu'un d'extraordinairement
humain et urbain j'ai dit toi tu viens
avec moi et tu vas livrer tous cet amour
vers les clients donc il est vite fait
devenu un peu mon assistant au adjoint
sur le côté service client et c'était
tout naturel quand je suis parti que qui
prennent la place dont il mérité tant
voilà donc un tel respect on va
travailler très bien ensemble alors on
va passer à l'organisation est-ce que
tout est prêt à environ un peu moins de
500 jours de ces Jeux Olympiques alors
tout est prêt alors ouais on va dire que
pour tout ce ce qui concerne le parcours
on connaît les talents qu'il y existent
au golf national au niveau de
l'entretien je dirais quotidien
du parcours de golf donc je pense qu'on
a aucun souci à voir par rapport à la
qualité du parcours même si quelques
standards et des normes vont changer
pour les équipes en place parce qu'on
est plus sur un modèle américain que sur
de livraison de l'événement que sur un
modèle européen
l'agronomiste conseil est un Américain
et bien la semaine prochaine d'ailleurs
pendant deux jours ce qui nous change un
petit peu on était tellement habitué à
setup d'un parcours de de préparer le
parcours pour les Européens et là on le
prépare pour un plateau mondial donc ça
ça peut changer après sur le reste de
l'organisation moi je suis très confiant
je vais dire oui parce que on a un plan
évidemment heureusement d'ailleurs à 500
jours mais des visites comme aujourd'hui
là je sors du Golf National aujourd'hui
était extrêmement productif avec toutes
les équipes de de structures
d'infrastructures de de du management de
l'événement les entrées publiques
comment on va faire les flux sur le site
parce que on vise quand même 25 à 30 000
personnes sur le site chaque jour il
faut pas oublier non plus que ce qui
nous change aussi c'est que la rider
c'était trois jours plus de jours
d'entraînement et là on est sur huit
jours de compétition ça change
concrètement le format rider avec le
format Jeux Olympiques 472 jours un très
exactement avant les cours j'ai vérifié
et appuyé sachant que c'est quand même
un format différent
c'est comme si on avait deux Open de
France
une semaine après l'autre une pour les
filles qui est qui est une opportunité
aussi pour nous tous parce que
bah en arrivant de Championship qui est
à Évian qui est un majeur mais le
National n'a pas vraiment accueilli non
plus un grand tournoi pour les pour les
filles jusqu'à maintenant et donc ça
c'est une opportunité mais deux semaines
de suite comme ça ça met une charge
importante sur le sur le parcours et sur
sur les équipes on attend pour une
dernière question Michael question un
peu piège pour vous Apollinaire est-ce
que vous allez soutenir l'équipe de
France ou la Grande-Bretagne pour les
Jeux Olympiques de 2024 alors c'est pas
une question piège je sais pas si vous
le savez mais juste avant de quitter le
Golf National j'ai obtenu la
naturalisation française donc je suis
français
mais par contre
le cas le 15 mars juste avant le
confinement j'ai reçu mon comment dire
ma lettre du Premier ministre en disant
voilà vous avez obtenu votre votre
nationalité donc je suis aussi français
que vous avec une acte de naissance mais
le cœur sportif malheureusement il est
toujours autre manche on précise alors
que la team Grande-Bretagne sera
accueillie dans les Yvelines du côté de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Olympiques qui
vont s'entraîner du coup au Camp des
Loges mais je crois aussi qui vont venir
faire quelques déplacements peut-être
sur le Golf National où ils vont rester
à Saint-Germain les peut-être pour les
entraînements
on rappelle juste que les épreuves de
golf sur ces Jeux Olympiques se
dérouleront du 1er au 4 août pour la
compétition masculine et du 7 au 10 août
pour le tournoi féminin Michael on
poursuit ses actualités sportives avec
une course de cyclisme mythique qui se
déroulait aujourd'hui la course Paris
camembert était programmée aujourd'hui
pour 194e édition les cyclistes se sont
élancés ce matin depuis à Magnanville
devant l'hôtel de ville les spectateurs
étaient au rendez-vous pour suivre le
départ de cette course cycliste du
Mantois qui n'était pas parti les
Yvelines depuis 2014 notre journaliste
Gabriel Gontier était sur place
après 8 ans d'attente Magnanville
retrouvée ce matin le départ de la
course cycliste Paris camembert malgré
la grisaille et le départ matinal le
public était nombreux à être venu
soutenir les 16 équipes qui se sont
élancées pour 200 km direction le
Calvados en fin de journée c'était un
beau départ
donc avec des beaux coureurs madois yo
Martin Perez donc je pense ça sera une
belle course et la course a été très
suivie dans la ville qui a vécu au
rythme de Paris camembert entre 1991 et
2014 oui je crois qu'il y a quand même
pas mal de retraités
donc et puis je pense qu'il y a des gens
qui ont fait l'effort aussi de peut-être
de prendre une demi-journée pour venir
parce que je pense que le cyclisme est
un sport qui attire beaucoup beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de de spectateurs ça a
toujours été un public de plus en plus
jeune cette année c'est près de 200
écoliers de la ville qui sont venus ce
matin soutenir les coureurs
si la course compte pour la Coupe de
France de cyclisme l'ambiance est avant
tout convivial et populaire peut avoir
le départ sur le village d'animation
était organisé l'incontournable
dégustation de camembert des ateliers
sur le vélo ainsi que la présentation
des équipes et des séances de dédicace
avec le public
au niveau de des Yvelines qui ont déjà
effectivement le départ de Paris Nice
donc les Yvelines c'est une terre de
vélo et de ce côté là on est pas mal
gâté une terre de vélo est plus
largement de sport que la course Paris
camembert réaffirme à l'approche des
Jeux de 2024 sur le territoire
mais une 84e édition qui a vu la
victoire de Valentin Ferron de la team
total énergie il s'est imposé le
Français au terme d'un sprint face à
Ewen costume la team Arkéa Samsic on va
continuer Mickael avec les résultats
sportifs du weekend il y avait du
football ce dimanche et la coupe des
Yvelines ont joué les demi-finales de
l'épreuve et les matchs ont été plutôt
serrés Conflans de cette imposé à
domicile face à Rambouillet Yvelines sur
le score de 2 à 0 de son côté
Aubergenville c'est imposé 2-1 face à
l'équipe 2 de Houilles la finale se
déroulera le 11 juin prochain dans la
commune de Maurepas le championnat
national mauvaise opération ça va mal
pour Versailles les Versailles n'y
arrivent plus dans cette fin de
championnat quatrième match sans
victoire les hommes de Chris ont arraché
le match nul dans le temps additionnel
sur la pelouse du Stade briochin grâce à
Gustave acquestone le score un but
partout classement les joueurs de la
cité royale ne sont plus les favoris
pour l’accession Ligue 2 ils sont pour
l'instant à la cinquième place à quatre
points du leader Martigues on joue
également sur les terrains de handball
en ce weekend 18e journée du championnat
de National 3 ce week-end plaisir les
clés a perdu à domicile face à
Saint-Mandé handball sur le score de 29
à 24 de son côté où il le Vésinet
carrière arrache la victoire 26 à 25 sur
le terrain de Loudéac 3e du championnat
au classement plaisir les clés et 9e et
le Vésinet et 5e à 4 journées de la fin
de la saison on parle de golf en golf la
livinois Antoine Rosner ne sera pas à
champion de France professionnel 2023 au
terme d'une journée à rebondissement
c'est Tom vaillant qui a eu l'honneur de
soulever le trophée Jean garayalde à 21
ans notre versaillée Antoine rosener
termine à trois coups à la septième
place du classement américain l'odeur on
parlait de foot US la semaine dernière
là c'est de baseball dont vous nous
parlez nickel direction
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce week-end des
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux fondé
en 1988 ont organisé au stade Jean
maréchal leur traditionnelle tournois de
pack soul soleil à un tournoi qui s'est
soldé par la victoire de l'équipe 2 des
inimontains l'occasion chaque année de
juger les forces de l'équipe en ce début
de saison l'équipe une et pour l'instant
en première de la poule A devant
Toulouse ou Rouen quels sont les
objectifs du club de cette pour cette
saison on écoute les réactions au micro
de TV 78 cette saison tout se passe bien
les nouveaux sont bien intégrés on a
toujours une bonne ambiance c'est ça qui
fait de notre force comme chaque année
pour l'instant tout va bien on a eu des
départs plus ou moins voulu et on a eu
des nouveaux arrivés donc les nouveaux
cette année on a un short stop qui nous
vient d'Espagne donc voilà Hector qui
s'intègre super bien au groupe et
surtout on a des jeunes qui nous
rejoignent donc Francis la Saline Kyoshi
Griso et Baptiste casobo qui sont des
jeunes qui sont au pôle qui sont ici du
club notre objectif c'est d'aller au
playoff et on va pas dévier de cette
tâche et voilà on fait tout on met tout
en œuvre pour arriver vraiment à aller
en finale
prochain match pour les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le 16 avril à
Toulouse c'est ce dimanche moi je suis
avec attention bien sûr leur saison
merci à Michael pour ses actualités
sportives et SLR et d'ouvrir une page
culturelle dans le 7 8
[Musique]
avec de nouvelles personnes en plateau
une nouvelle personne Véronique
Ithurbide bonsoir Véronique
pour vos insolites les informations qui
ont peut-être échappé à l'attention de
nos téléspectateurs vous nous avez
concocté quoi ce soir alors j'ai trouvé
pour vous bah je vais vous parler d'un
lieu qui est à Versailles que je ne
connaissais pas et dans ce lieu il y a
un autre lieu dont je vous ai parlé
aussi c'est en fait un tiers-lieux dans
lequel se trouve un potager en
agroécologie et qui propose des
formations enfin on va parler écologie
permaculture plein de choses comme ça
voilà dans un instant dans le 7 8 et on
va parler aussi d'un projet insolite
tout de suite qui pourrait peut-être
intégrer vos informations insolites qui
mêlent théâtre et aussi magie pour
aborder les mécanismes de la
manipulation le spectacle Cérébro sera
proposé ce samedi 15 avril du côté du
scarabée à La Verrière l'horaire 20h30 à
la baguette Mathieu villatel de la
compagnie du Pharo qui est avec nous par
visio bonsoir
bonsoir vous nous entendez bien alors
Cérébro vous l'avez co-écrit avec Kurt
deux mecs qui signent également la mise
en scène et c'est un spectacle qui est
avant tout nu avant tout une
sensibilisation ludique aux techniques
de manipulation pourquoi c'est un sujet
que vous avez voulu traiter
parce que le mentalisme en fait c'est un
art du mensonge c'est le même outil que
le magicien on fait croire de des choses
fausses et donc on pose la question du
vrai et du faux et aussi ça pose des
questions de rapport de pouvoir et donc
je trouvais que c'était un outil
intéressant pour parler de la
manipulation la croyance c'est une
question centrale dans votre travail
c'est quoi votre constat les gens sont
enclin facilement à faire confiance aux
autres finalement le cerveau est
facilement malléable
je crois que les spécialistes des biais
cognitives vous savez les failles de
notre cerveau disent que même lorsqu'ils
sont formés qui connaissent très très
bien les biais ils continuent à tomber
dedans c'est très très difficile en fait
de se préparer ou de se prémunir face à
la manipulation
et alors dans cérébraux vous êtes
migouroux mis coach de vie d'ailleurs le
spectacle est en fait un faux programme
de développement personnel qui va
permettre aux spectateur de révéler leur
véritable potentiel ce genre de
programme de technique on a quand même
l'impression ces dernières années que ça
pullule des livres sur le développement
personnel des spectacles sur le
développement personnel on en a vu des
milliers alors des milliers peut-être
pas mais des dizaines ces dernières
années
c'est ça oui c'est ça que je trouvais
aussi très intéressant c'est que
maintenant c'est assez facile de devenir
coach en développement personnel on
envoie en effet de plus en plus
notamment sur les sur les plateformes et
c'est pas forcément des gens qui ont
une formation très très poussée et en
fait très rapidement on peut on peut
monter un institut de coaching et donc
c'est ce qu'on fait là au théâtre
alors le but c'est de montrer
non non allez-y le mentalisme oui ça
permet
ça permet de très vite faire croire
qu'on a des capacités développées et des
capacités un peu surhumaines et alors le
but c'est de montrer tout le processus
d'embrigadement ça se fait étape par
étape je crois que c'est ce que vous
appelez le l'escalier de la de la
croyance c'est ça
ouais tout à fait l'idée c'est de voir
comment on peut petit à petit accorder
la confiance et comme c'est difficile
une fois que la confiance est en place
de revenir de dessus c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de parler de la
manipulation mais de l'endroit où en
fait on se on se retrouve à aller là où
on n'a pas forcément envie d'aller au
départ
alors le tout je le disais de manière
ludique parce que vous avez vous allez
utiliser la magie au cours de ce
spectacle comment vous l'utilisez
justement
la magie on le spectacle elle est à la
fois partout et en même temps un peu
nulle part c'est à dire que c'est que
des expériences de magie mais c'est
beaucoup des c'est très interactif donc
c'est beaucoup des personnes du public
qui la pratiquent et qui montrent qu'en
fait très vite je peux les former qui
peuvent avoir des capacités
particulières et on l'a écrit pour
qu'elle soit à la fois forte mais en
même temps assez crédible aussi pour
qu'on puisse se dire ah mais en fait
peut-être que c'est vrai peut-être qu'on
peut apprendre à faire ce genre de
choses
alors comment vous l'avez préparé ce
spectacle vous êtes beaucoup intéressé
notamment à la Scientologie les
mécanismes de la scientologie
alors pas que la Scientologie mais en
effet pas mal de mouvements sectaires
parce que la secte c'est un peu
poussiéreux mais je crois que par contre
la manipulation sectaire elle est encore
très présente et notamment sur les sur
les réseaux sociaux et on la voit de
plus en plus et donc ce qui
m'intéressait c'est quels sont les
processus qui sont mis en place pour
voilà nous nous amener à plonger en
quelque sorte et donc ça veut dire que
quand on va venir voir ce spectacle le
spectateur justement va sortir de là en
ayant un quelques clés pour être un peu
plus vigilant à l'avenir c'est ça aussi
ça le but
oui alors en même temps je crois pas que
le spectacle soit qu'il est une morale
souvent en tant qu'artiste on vient
partager des questionnements qu'on se
pose sur le monde avec les spectateurs
et moi je viens donner mon point de vue
sur la manipulation mon point de vue de
mentalisme mais je crois qu'on repart
avec plus de questions peut-être que
qu'avec de réponse c'est
un spectacle ça va être la cinquième
saison et là vous vous êtes actuellement
dans un théâtre pour jouer le spectacle
ce soir peut-être
oui je suis à la lanterne à Rambouillet
d'accord oui donc un spectacle qui tombe
dans les Yvelines Rambouillet c'est
aujourd'hui c'est ce soir et donc il
sera joué du côté de la verrière samedi
15 avril je rappelle juste un l'horaire
c'est 20h30 et on peut avoir toutes les
informations et aussi on peut réserver
son billet sur le site
kiosque.sqy.fr merci Mathieu il attelle
d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous pour ce spectacle donc
Cérébro qui sera juste je le rappelle ce
samedi du côté de la verrière jusqu'au 8
juillet l'exposition space se tient au
Musée de la Ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais leur
histoire de la conquête spatiale et
design du XXe siècle l'exposition met en
avant le mouvement artistique futuriste
et utopique du spaceage Frédéric debuche
fait découvrir l'exposition à Gabriel
Gonthier Julien Leroy
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve
aujourd'hui au musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour découvrir
l'exposition spaceage et nous allons
retrouver Frédéric debuch directeur du
musée et commissaire de l'exposition
en quelques mots comment vous pouvez
nous la présenter cette exposition c'est
une exposition qui est consacrée au
design inspiré par la conquête de
l'espace alors la conquête de l'espace
commence globalement après la guerre
notamment dans les années 50 petit tour
maintenant vers l'exposition dans les
créations ont été inspirées par la
conquête spatiale reprenant les
caractéristiques du mouvement artistique
spacage effet mère futuriste et utopique
[Musique]
bon alors la première chose qui
m'interpelle quand j'arrive ici moi dans
cette pièce c'est ce téléviseur portable
en forme de casque de cosmonaute
effectivement c'est l'un des objets
assez emblématiques de cette thématique
du spaceage et de par conséquent
d'exposition qui illustre aussi le fait
que le spaced était vraiment un
phénomène
international et qui inspirait les
créateurs de la planète entière cette
télé est sortie en 1970 c'est à dire
pendant la durée la mission Apollon 11
qui a vu la conquête lunaire il y a
d'autres objets qu'on a réunis dans
cette salle comme ici par le recul de
l'histoire
se mobilier est devenu un petit peu
associé à ce qu'on qualifie de de Space
Age
et on rappelle que l'exposition spacef
se tient jusqu'au 8 juillet 2023 au
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une exposition
qui ont l'a dit est accessible à tous
[Musique]
vous êtes prêtes c'est parti pour les
insolites
et on débute ses insolites par la mise
en lumière d'un tiers-lieux qui propose
des formations en agroécologie son nom
c'est l'Ermitage et qui est engagé pour
l'humain et la terre
écologique je vais vous expliquer un peu
alors déjà il se trouve dans un lieu un
peu particulier c'est-à-dire dans
l'ancienne demeure de la marquise de
Pompadour c'est un parc d'un hectare
ethnique et qui fait à la bordure du
parc du château
et c'est Louis XV qui donc avait offert
ce cette demeure elle a marquise de
Pompadour sa favorite demeure bâtie en
1746 voilà donc ce lieu se tiers-lieux
existe depuis 24 ans et c'est le siège
social d'une d'un mouvement
international qui a été créée par des
laïcs chrétiens et qui s'appelle
fondation alors ceux qui veulent en
savoir plus peuvent aller voir leur
situation c'est en fait ce sont des gens
qui sont réunis pour vivre une sorte de
cohérence entre l'écologie la justice
sociale le développement personnel le
spirituel voilà ça m'a fait rire tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
là on est sur du vrai de la qualité et
donc les rapports humains sont mis en
avant etc et on n'oublie pas la nature
donc fort de ces points là ils ont donc
qui proposent des formations soit sur le
cheminement personnel le développement
spirituel des formations aussi
professionnelles il propose d'accueillir
enfin ils accueillent des des
sans-abris soit des sans-papiers soit
des des enfin des gens dans le besoin
d'être logé comme ça et héberger il y a
une trentaine de places et il y a aussi
un comment dire un potager justement
c'est là où je voulais venir en venir
c'est un potager qui fait 200 m², il y a
aussi un poulailler un compost un verger
et ce fameux potager 200 mètres carrés
en agroécologie alors est-ce que je peux
permettre sans douter tout ce que je
veux
on a quand même un temps imparti mais
allez-y
c'est pas pour vous offenser mais je
veux en vivre donner deux petites
définition donc l'agroécologie c'est
c'est l'ensemble des méthodes de
production agricole respectueuse dans
l'environnement il faut un Besta et la
permaculture ça fait la même chose si
une approche globale qui vise à
concevoir réaliser maintenir des
systèmes économiquesment durables
socialement équitable et prenant exemple
sur les écus thèmes naturels dans quel
but mon cher Grégory dans le but de
préserver la terre de préserver l'homme
de créer l'abondance et puis quand il y
en a trop bah il y en a pas trop
puisqu'on peut le redistrer au copains
voilà donc fort de ça ah tiens un tout
petit peu d'histoire encore allez en
1928 le terme agroécologie est arrivé
aux États-Unis avec Basile benssin bref
sûrement quelqu'un très
engagé là-dedans évidemment
et le japonais Massano bu futuhaka il a
inspiré ce modèle l'agroécologie en
écrivant un livre qui s'appelle la
révolution d'un seul brin de paille en
1975 alors moi ça me faisait penser à
zelbrenpai à la fameuse goutte d'eau du
Colibri du regretté Pierre Rabhi voilà
ça c'est la mise en lumière de
l'Ermitage on est dans quelle ville
pardon on est dans quelle ville on est à
Versailles à Versailles
j'ai un doute sur le fait qu'on est
précisé
au tout début ça a été précisé avait
bien envie que que ça favorite ne soit
pas trop loin donc il l'a Legé près du
parc de rappel ne fait pas mal
d'ailleurs on va enchaîner avec une
piqûre de rappel un photomaton on se
fait tirer le portrait dans un
photomaton
je me dépêche bon alors dans cette
formation en agroécologie Sandrine
Barraine elle qui est formée à ça qui a
eu une passion pour la nature le potager
c'est formé pendant trois ans elle a
exercé ses connaissances pour elle-même
elle a vu que ça marchait très bien et
elle est devenue formatrice et elle a un
label de formatrice justement très très
sérieux dont je ne retrouve pas le nom
ah oui caliopie la belle de qualité pour
les formateurs voilà elle vous propose
une journée 9h17h dans ce fameux potager
de l'Ermitage à Versailles vous allez
apprendre tout ce qu'il faut pour
démarrer vous-même un potager soit
permaculture ou agroécologique voilà et
vous aurez vraiment les bases vous serez
mis le pied à l'étrier ça coûte 145
euros qui a une formation par mois on
n'est pas plus de 12 et la prochaine et
21 avril voilà Sandrine Barraine elle
nous a envoyé des très belles photos
j'espère que seulement
bon alors le sol si jamais vous voulez
le sol n'est jamais élaboré ni retourner
nourri avec en surface par des déchets
organiques et du compost voilà la faune
et la flore sont respectées et
l'environnement est ainsi très fertile
les plantes
produisent énormément de très bonne
qualité pleines de bons nutriments pour
notre petite santé et résistent encore
mieux aux maladies et à ses méchants
ravageurs qui sont les limaces les
escargots et les dories forts
en plus on économise de l'essence parce
qu'on la bourre pas et gnagnagna vous
avez envie que je termine non non c'est
très intéressant
à Versailles je faisais une piqûre de
rappel sur sur le lieu puisque vous
vouliez faire aussi une autre piqûre de
rappel alors juste le photomaton on est
d'accord on se fait tirer le portrait
voilà ma transition on va pouvoir la
faire on est d'accord alors là c'est
exactement c'est un photomaton un peu
particulier ça se passe ce 16 avril et
c'est un photomaton poésie
donc c'est la librairie la suite rue du
bayage à Versailles qui organise ça
c'est un photomaton bricolé en deux
personnes construit en deux parties vous
rentrez dedans c'est pour enfant ou
adulte c'est l'après-midi c'est gratuit
vous pouvez y aller vous si c'est une
émotion colère joie n'importe quoi et un
professeur de lettres aura sélectionné
des poèmes 19e 20e et trois comédiens
seront là cachés pour vous les lire avec
toutes l'émotion et et
le ton qu'il faut etc et voilà on vous
dit un poème pour vous vous repartez
avec de découvrir la poésie
de montrer qu'elle est accessible à tous
les âges et qu'il y a plein de poètes
formidables à découvrir
tout est dit merci Véronique merci
beaucoup on vous retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine pour les insolites pas
le coup de Me Squeezie
l'Ermitage
on va terminer cette émission avec une
rencontre est-ce que vous êtes burger
alors ça fait partie des plats préférés
des français le burger avec la pizza je
me demande pourquoi vous me posez la
question
les burgers font partie de ma liste
classique
mais oui oui j'aime bien plutôt les
classiques plutôt Véronique non
j'aimerais mais je ne peux pas tout ce
qui est bon et mauvais pour moi d'accord
peut-être
végétariens ou même light ça doit
exister moi je pense à mentionner body
un peu comme tout le monde et j'éviterai
les burgers pour l'instant l'été elle
était approche alors la rencontre c'est
avec Anthony potra qui est chef au up to
you un restaurant à montign le
Bretonneux restaurant bas et depuis
plusieurs mois il s'entraîne pour une
compétition un peu particulière la Coupe
de France des burgers le concours est
organisé par la Société de
conditionnement des produits agricoles
et va se dérouler demain à Paris le
cuisinier l'un des cinq candidats
représentés l'Île-de-France ont fait ça
en contre avec Céline Charles et Julien
Laurent précision rigueur et travail ce
sont les ingrédients nécessaires à la
confection d'un burger de compétition
[Musique]
fromage aux oignons caramélisés
mayonnaise herbacée ou encore bacon au
piment d'Espelette ce burger permettra
peut-être à Anthony Potterat d'être
sacré champion de France le cuisinier de
27 ans s'est classé parmi les 25
meilleurs sur 350 participants à la
présélection en ligne du concours sur le
thème du rock n' roll tout autour je
vais enflammer la scène au moment de
l'envoi donc le burger sera en haut les
flammes en sucre et ici il y aura un
rideau de feu qui va qui va carrément
enflammer le présentoir il faut pas
tomber dans le cliché américain il faut
pas tomber dans des dans des choses qui
se sont déjà vues donc
ça a été compliqué j'ai fait énormément
d'essais énormément de remise en
question sur les associations que je
pouvais apporter tout le monde sait
faire des Bombers mais des burgers pour
être champion de France c'est plus du
tout la même compétition c'est plus du
tout la même la même vision du burger et
vraiment j'ai poussé la recette et le
burger au
plus haut point possible pâtissier
pendant 10 ans et passer par plusieurs
grandes maisons anthony est arrivé au
restaurant lobe to you à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en 2022 il
participera avec son burger à la finale
régionale puis nationale à Paris les
candidats ont 25 minutes pour en
confectionner 4 une épreuve qui lui
demande beaucoup d'entraînement je me
chronomètre dans tout ce que je fais
tout est chronométré je prends vraiment
la compétition comme comme un sportif
aux Jeux Olympiques qui doit grappiller
des centièmes de seconde des centièmes
des centièmes pour que le jour J y est
une marge d'erreur qui soit la plus fine
possible pour avoir ce résultat là j'ai
passé mon nombre bon nombre d'essais bon
nombre de remise en question bon nombre
de recettes que j'ai retravaillés que
j'ai perfectionné jusqu'à temps que le
résultat ne soit pas correct j'ai
recommencé jour et nuit donc ça a été ça
a été intense j'ai envie de rendre fier
tout le monde j'ai envie de trahir
personne que ça soit mon coach qui me
suit mes amis mes proches ma famille mes
collègues je peux pas décevoir je peux
plus décevoir qui que ce soit maintenant
je vais aller au bout de la compétition
ramenez la coupe à définit le Bretonneux
pour être offrir Anthony une belle
reconnaissance professionnelle après
plusieurs années au fourneau réponse le
12 avril
on espère Michael qui va ramener la
coupe à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
qui a l'air très très gourmand quand
même hein
donc je compte y aller un jour bonne
chance en tout cas Anthony poutra qui
sera donc engagé demain dans cette Coupe
de France des burgers avant de se
quitter on va jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil aux prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
il va falloir patienter encore un peu
avant de retrouver les conditions météo
du week-end pascal des nuages au menu de
votre matinée de mercredi dans le
département côté température comptiez 9
degrés sur les secteurs de
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans eversize 8
degrés à Rambouillet dans l'après-midi
attention le temps sera orageux et les
Yvelines seront en vigilance jaune au
vent prévoyez 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles Rambouillet
et 12 degrés du côté de Houdan voilà
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité et demain un mercredi vous
retrouverez Mathilde Franco à la
présentation d'un nouveau 7 8 très belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]